President Trump says there is no
infighting in the White House over Iran
and he rejects reports that he is
frustrated with advisers who want the
u.s. to take strong action against Iran
administration officials will brief
congressional leaders today on the
threat they see two Americans in that
region David Martin is at the Pentagon
with more on this story David good
morning to you good morning US officials
insist they have hard evidence on the
threat from Iran including pictures of
ballistic missiles loaded on Iranian
boats but until the Trump administration
produces some of this intelligence there
will be questions about how this
confrontation began and where it is
headed
we believe that escalation of tension in
the region is not in the interest of
anybody overnight in Tokyo iran's
Foreign Minister criticized the u.s. for
unnecessary provocation Iran will not be
a party beginning escalation but we will
certainly defend ourselves and respond
back at home lawmakers on both sides are
demanding details on specific Iranian
threats I have no idea of what the
threat stream is beyond what I read in
the paper we should be getting a
briefing and we should be getting it
before there are more concerning
developments in the region
administration is engaged in a series of
blind escalations without any endgame
there is also skepticism among US allies
including the Iraqis in part because
some of the intelligence originated with
Israel the US officials insist the
original tips from Israel have been
confirmed by American intelligence this
threat is real a senior State Department
official told reporters Democrats raised
the specter of the 2003 invasion of Iraq
when the u.s. went to war on the false
belief Saddam Hussein was hiding weapons
of mass destruction we were falsely led
into a military engagement in Iraq which
is one of the biggest mistakes we have
had in foreign policy but the American
military buildup continues a Carrier
Strike Group headed by the USS Lincoln
has now arrived in waters south of the
entrance to the Persian Gulf
Noora all of these developments
incredibly important to watch David
thank you